oh
[Musique]
aligot tartiflette raclette ou burger au
foie gras nous ne sommes pas au coeur
des massifs de la savoie mais bien dans
les yvelines ce restaurant a décidé
durant l'hiver d'accueillir ses clients
dans une ambiance chalet vous êtes
vraiment dans le chalet où on a fait
l'ambiance un petit peu peau de bête on
a mis des jolis mots qu est un petit peu
couleurs sapin on a un joli on a aussi
les des coussins qui sont couleur un
petit peu l'hiver donc c'est vraiment
cette ambiance qu'on a voulu donner
comme dans un chalet avec du sapin du
boulot des pommes de pin des petites
bougies et puis beaucoup de chaleur
beaucoup de chauffage décoré et cartes
de saison pour la maison louveciennes
situé quai conti pour les desserts le
vin chaud côtoient guimauve et churros
et bien c'est très sympa c'est très cosy
les villes de la chaleur est très
agréable ça fait une ambiance très cool
c'est très sympa le temps n'est pas avec
nous aujourd'hui mais c'est très très
chouette propriétaire du lieu depuis
2019 et chef de cuisine david shulman
s'affairent quotidiennement auprès de
ses équipes après avoir connu la haute
gastronomie avec alain ducasse et joël
robuchon il a fait le choix de la
banlieue parisienne pour une nouvelle
aventure bistronomique comprenait une
cuisine abordable mais avec une pointe
d'élégance je voudrais vous proposer
comme je vous l'expliquais tout à
l'heure de mettre un petit monde or dans
notre four à braise pour vous expliquer
un petit peu comment on fait
comment on fait notre athlète
à la mer au chalet de la maison nous
tiennent donc on a la chance d'avoir ce
joli barbecue et là on va commencer à
faire fondre notre notre mont d'or et
pendant que je pendant que c'est en
train de se préparer on à sébastien qui
est en train de préparer la ligue au
donc cette cure et dans laquelle on dans
laquelle on met généreusement de la
tomme de savoie une cinquantaine de
personnes travaillent ici avec lui pour
redonner vie à cet établissement laissé
à l'abandon il ya encore deux ans son
pari semble réussi malgré la crise
sanitaire et dans quelques semaines la
maison l'ancien quittera son manteau
d'hiver et le chalet deviendra stations
balnéaires comme l'an dernier la carte
s'adaptera au réchauffement des
températures et en retour du soleil
toujours les pieds dans l'eau en bord de
seine